قسم مدفعيه استهدف مبنى اداره السكك
الحديديه وسطى مدينه دونياسك الليله
الماضيه سلطات قالت بان القوات الاوكرانيه
اطلقت سته قذائف مدفعيه من طراز 155 ملم
على هذا المبنى وهو مبنى اداره السكك
الحديديه في مركز مدينه دنياك طبعا هذا
القصف خلف
حريقا كبيرا ما زالت فرق الاطفاء تحاول
اخماده بشكل كامل ولكن السلطات قالت بان
بانه لم يكن هناك اي ضحايا في صفوف
المدنيين او حتى الموظفين باعتبار ان
القذف جرى عند حدود الساعه الثالثه همم
صباحا وبالتالي كان هذا المبنى خاليا ترون
اعمده الدخان ما زال تتصاعد الحريق لم يتم
اطفائه بشكل كامل
وطبعا هذا لم يكن القصف الوحيد الذي همم
الذي
مدينه دنياسك وجوارها الليله الماضيه
وصباح اليوم حيث تعرضت مدينه
مكيفا المجاوره ايضا لقصف مدفعي اوكراني
وبعض البلدات التي تقع قرب خطوط التماس
خاصه في الجهه الغربيه وايضا الشماليه من
مدينه دنياك